♪ ♪ ♪
(en espagnol)
- Hola!
- Cette t t t t t l'unique
fenêtre vers le monde extérieur
pour Manolo, Georgina et Manuel.
des visiteurs, ils ne peuvent
enasasasasas franchir le seuil.
(en espagnol)
"Si on sort, on risque
le père de famille.
Les Rodriguerororororororororor.
À leur arrivée au pays,
il leur est impossible
d'obtenir un statut de réfugié,
mais i t t t t t t t t t t t t ,
ils occupent plusieurs emplois,
s'intègrent à la communauté.
Mais l'an dernier,
un avis d'expulsion.
Pas question de retourner
au Mexique où ils craignent
(en espagnol)
Georgina avait une cafétéria.
auraient brûlé son commerce
alors qu'ioyoyoyoyoyaient
à l'intérieur parce qu'elle
aurait refusé de les laisser
dans son restaurant.
(eololololol)
dit-elle. L'an dernier,
à pareille  f f f f famille
ne voit qu'une dernière option :
se réfugier dans cette église en
un principe qui n'a aucune
assie,e,e,e,e, mais qui,
dans les faits, est respecté
par les autorités.
Jamais ils n'auraient cru
y passer une année complète.
(en espagnol)
"C'est très difficile,
confie-t-elle. Il me demande
chaque jour quand pourrons-nou
sortir. Tout ce que je peux
lui dire, c'est : prions."
- You like Canada?
- Yeah!
t t t t t de rentrer ici,
Manolo allait à l'école.
Maintenant, ce sont
ses enseignants qui viennent
à lui. Aujourd'hui,
c'est cours d'anglais.
Qu'est-ce qui te
- Hum...
Aller à l'école et travailler
puis sortir avec mes amis.
- Mon intentdedededededededededr
de l'église.
- Mais sortir vient avec
un grand risque, celui
Leur avocat Stewart Istvanffy
souhaite que le gouvernement
fasse preuve de clémence.
avocat de la famille
- Et c c c c crois que
la demande est assez forte
et bien fondée. Moi, je crois
quelqu'un regarde leur demande
s s s s se faire déporter.
(en espagnol)
- "Le moment est venu,
dit Georginaotototototre santé
mentale, notre décision
est prise. Nous sommes prêts
à sortir de l'église
et à courir ce r
La famille espère que
le ministre de l'Immigration
Sean Fraser leur accorde
pour motif humanitaire.
ÉLISABETH BRIÈRE, députée, Parti
libéral du Canada, Sherbrooke
- Je ne peux pas leur donner
aucune garavavavavavavavavavava.
- À Ottawa, la députée libérale
de Sherbrooke assure faire tout
ce qu'elle peut pour les aider.
Elle a interpellé le mepepepepe.
(tic-tac)
- Les minutes passent,
le jour présent est t t t t t te
celui de demain. Ils sontunununi
sur une base régulière.
Des repas comme celui-là,
Dansokho en a partagé
des dizaines avec
SAMUEL VAUVERT-DANSOKHO,
pasteue e e e e Plymouth-Trinity
- Ça, c'est une expérience
humaine qui n'a pas de prix
le reste de ma vie.
- La famille rêve d
un nouveau chapitre.
Georgina s'imagine ouvrir
à Sherbrooke. Mais d'ici là,
elle n'a qu'un seul souhait :
(en espagnol)
"La liberté, le cadeau d'une vie
pouresesesesesesesesesesesesese)
Ici Marion Bérubé,
Radio